This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Morris. I don't have a favorite podcast. It'd be too unfair. There are too many I like. It is hard to choose just one. But when people ask me that question, I always make sure to mention the radio topia show Song Exploder.
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我没有最喜欢的播客，因为那样太不公平了。我喜欢的播客太多了，很难只选出一个。但每当人们问我这个问题时，我总是会提到 Radiotopia 旗下的节目《歌曲解密》（Song Exploder）。
I think it is the perfect concept for a podcast. If you haven't heard it, my friend, Rishikesh Hereway, he interviews musical artists and gets them to break down a song into its component parts to show how it all came together. It's recently been adapted into a Netflix TV show is so much fun to watch, I hope you check it out. And we love song exploder here on the show so much that in a meeting a few months ago,
我认为这是最完美的播客概念。如果你没听过，我的朋友里希凯什·赫尔威（Rishikesh Hirway）会采访音乐人，让他们把一首歌拆解成各个组成部分，展示这一切是如何融合到一起的。它最近被改编成了 Netflix 的电视节目，观看过程非常有趣，我希望你们去看看。而且我们节目组所有人都非常喜欢《歌曲解密》，以至于在几个月前的一次会议上，
we thought, well, what if we tried to do that for one of our own songs? You might know that we have our own composer here at Nae and I'm PI, her name is Sean Rial, and hiring her was one of the best decisions I've ever made. I love that we have our own and house composer. I love working with Sean, and Sean works with all the producers to score our episodes with original music that she writes and records right here in Oakland. So, on this episode, we are bringing you a tribute to the Brilliant Podcast song exploder and our brilliant composer, Sean Riel,
我们想，如果我们试着为我们自己的其中一首歌做这件事会怎么样？你可能知道我们这里有一位专属作曲家，在 99PI，她叫肖恩·里尔（Sean Rial）。聘请她是这辈子做过最好的决定之一。我很高兴我们拥有自己的专属作曲家，我喜欢和肖恩合作。肖恩与所有的制作人合作，为我们的单集节目创作并录制原创音乐，而这一切就发生在这里——奥克兰。所以，在本期节目中，我们要向伟大的播客《歌曲解密》以及我们伟大的作曲家肖恩·里尔致敬，
and we're calling it, Sean Exploder. It's the story of a song that Sean wrote for Avery Chouppenman back when she worked here. It's called The Loom, and it's the first song in Avery's spin-off series, Articles of Interest. And to tell the story of the song, you really need to start at the beginning of Avery and Shawn's relationship. I'll let Shawn take it from here.
我们把它叫做《肖恩解密》（Sean Exploder）。这是一个关于肖恩为埃弗里·特雷夫曼（Avery Truffleman）以前在这里工作时写的一首歌的故事。这首歌叫做《织机》（The Loom），它是埃弗里衍生系列节目《衣冠楚楚》（Articles of Interest）中的第一首歌。要讲这首歌的故事，你真的得从埃弗里和肖恩关系的起点说起。接下来我就把时间交给肖恩。
Hi, my name is Shawn Riel. I'm the composer for 99% Invisible. I've been with the show for four years now, but before that I was playing music in bands and making a living walking dogs. Dog walking is actually mostly driving and picking up dogs, so like a lot of listening to stuff in the car. And at a certain point you just like get sick of music, so that's when I started like religiously listening to podcasts and I couldn't like refresh the feed fast enough. And the music was a big part of it too. Like I think like that was a big part of like what made it feel like this new kind of
嗨，我叫肖恩·里尔。我是《99%无形》的作曲家。我已经加入这个节目四年了，但在那之前，我一直在乐队里玩音乐，靠遛狗维持生计。遛狗其实大部分时间都在开车和接狗，所以有很多时间在车里听各种东西。到了某个时刻，你就会对音乐感到厌烦，所以也就是在那时，我开始狂热地听播客，而且觉得怎么也刷不够新的节目。音乐也是其中很大的一部分。就像我认为，这也是让我觉得这是一种全新艺术形式的重要原因。
art for me. And part of me thought like I could write that music. But then I thought you know they probably just pull from some music library or something. There's not like one person who writes music for podcasts, and so then I would kind of just put it out of my head. I was getting to a point where working all day and then, you know, like going home and trying to find the energy to work on music with my bands's little teeth and basement. The sustainability had run out. I was emotionally and energetically bankrupt. It's like trying to be like, there has to be a way out of this without like writing a hit song that's going to make me rich and famous. Like, there has to be a way to make this a living.
我有时会想，我也能写那种音乐。但转念一想，你知道的，他们可能只是从什么音乐库里随便抽几首。并不是有一个专人为播客写音乐，所以我就把这个想法从脑子里赶出去了。我当时正处于这样一种状态：整天工作，然后，你知道的，回家还要努力挤出精力在地下室里和我的乐队成员们一起做音乐，这种可持续性已经耗尽了。我在情感和精力上都破产了。这就像是在说，一定有一种出路，不需要写出一首能让我发财成名的热单。就像是，一定有办法把这个当成生计。
And then I met Avery. Hi, I'm Avery Treffleman. I am the host of the podcast, The Cut from New York Magazine. But for most of my life, I worked at 99% invisible. Sean and I met on OKCupid, which is now considered like the old fashioned way to meet someone.
然后我遇到了埃弗里。嗨，我是埃弗里·特雷夫曼。我是《纽约客》杂志旗下播客《裁决》（The Cut）的主持人。但在我生命中的大部分时间里，我都曾在《99%无形》工作。我和肖恩是在 OKCupid 上认识的，现在这已经被认为是认识人的老派方式了。
It's like Quaint, when you hear that someone met on OKC someone. It's like quaint when you hear that someone met on OKCupid. It's like, oh, that's romance. You had to read a whole profile. One of the stupid questions OKCupid asked you is like, what's the first thing people noticed about you? And I was like, my voice. And I think Sean responded and said something
当你听说有人是通过 OKCupid 认识的时候，会觉得有点古怪。就像是，哦，那是浪漫。你必须阅读一整份个人资料。OKCupid 会问你的那些蠢问题之一就是，别人对你的第一印象是什么？而我说：我的声音。我想肖恩回复时也说了一些……
and like, you know, I have a pretty signature voice too. And so we started sharing these voice memos back and forth for like a long time before we ever met, we had this very like radio courtship. I remember like walking down to the office, like walking down telegraph avenue, three miles, like blah, blah, blah, like leaving voice memos for Sean. One time I was like just recording a voice memo,
你知道的，我的声音也相当具有标志性。于是我们开始来来回回分享这些语音备忘录，持续了很长时间，甚至在我们见面之前，我们就已经有了一种非常像广播式的恋爱过程。我记得走去办公室的那段路，沿着电报大道（Telegraph Avenue）走三英里，巴拉巴拉地给肖恩留语音备忘录。有一次我正录着语音备忘录，
and then I looked at, I was like, oh god, this is 45 minutes. I'm about to like send a 45 minute voice memo, and I texted her and I was like, oh God, this is 45 minutes. I'm about to like send a 45 minute voice memo and I texted you and I was like, this is 45 minutes. Is this too much? And you responded, you know, I'm about to get on the plane. Please send it now. I need something to listen to.
然后我看了一眼，心想：“天哪，这都45分钟了。我难道要发一个45分钟的语音备忘录吗？”我给她发信息说：“天哪，这都45分钟了。我难道要发一个45分钟的语音备忘录吗？”我给你发信息说：“这有45分钟。会不会太多了？”而你回复说：“你知道吗，我正要上飞机。快发过来，我需要听点东西。”
I distinctly remember that. I distinctly remember being like, download, download, download, like before the plane took off. Like, it was so fun. Yeah. So we like exchange voice memos for, like, it was so fun. Yeah, so we like exchanged voice members for a long, long time before ever meeting. And then we finally met. And I spent a lot of time hanging out in Sean's house,
我清楚地记得那个情景。我清楚地记得当时心里一直在喊：下载、下载、下载，就在飞机起飞前。真的太有趣了。对，所以我们交换语音备忘录……真的太有趣了。对，所以在面基之前，我们很长很长一段时间都在互相发语音消息。然后我们终于见面了。我花了很多时间在肖恩家晃悠，
going to Sean's shows, like getting to know all the band drama, Sean's band. We dated, I think it was four months. We dated for a while. And then honestly, this musical relationship was sort of our way back to friendship. So I was working on this story called Miss Manhattan. And it was a story about the most famous model in all of New York.
去现场看肖恩的演出，了解肖恩乐队的所有八卦。我们约会了，我想大概是四个月吧。我们交往了一段时间。说实话，这种音乐上的合作关系某种程度上成了我们回归友谊的桥梁。当时我正在做一个叫《曼哈顿小姐》（Miss Manhattan）的故事。这是一个关于纽约最著名模特的故事。
She appears on statues all over the city and also in other cities across America. She was a famous artist model. And this was a story about one woman's life and it was very dramatic and more cinematic than anything I'd tried to cover in the past. And I realized that a lot of the music beds we used were like these rhythmic jams that sort of keep you humming along but this was a story with real high highs and low lows like I wanted it to be
她的雕像出现在全城的各个地方，也出现在美国其他城市的雕像上。她是一位著名的艺术家模特。这个故事讲述了一个女人的生平，非常具有戏剧性，比我过去尝试报道过的任何内容都要有电影感。我意识到，我们过去使用的很多音乐垫底都只是一些节奏感强的果酱音乐，只能让你跟着哼唱，但这是一个有着极高情绪起伏和低谷的故事，我想让它配乐起来几乎就像一部电影。
scored almost like a film. I didn't know a lot of musicians and I thought a shun. For Avery to be like would you want to make some music for 99% invisible? I was just like, whoa. It felt, yeah, it's like a dream come true. But thing in that I thought could never actually be a real thing was actually possible. I mean, working with Sean felt like mixing paint for the first time. You know, before it felt a little paint by numbers, I was like, okay, oh, you got, you know, this is a good song we like to use when things get happy. And this is a good like plotting, talky-talk song. I used to call the genre Thought Core.
我认识的音乐家不多，我想到了肖恩。对于埃弗里来说，邀请她“你想不想为《99%无形》做点音乐？”时，我的反应简直是：哇。感觉，是的，就像梦想成真一样。那些以前觉得永远不可能真正实现的事情，居然真的成了可能。我的意思是，与肖恩合作就像是第一次调配颜料。你知道，以前感觉有点像是按数字填色，我会想：好吧，哦，你知道的，这是一首适合事情变得开心时用的好歌。这是一首适合那种沉闷、唠叨的好歌。我过去把这种曲风叫做“思想核心”（Thought Core）。
That was like, then you add the plinky plunks, they're like, boop, boop, boop, boop, like music to talk over. And then Sean was able to address all of these different nuances. And the way is the story can take a turn, you can have music that moves with the narrative. And I didn't even realize how badly I wanted that.
就像是，然后你再加上叮叮咚咚的声音，就像是，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，就像是可以边说话边播放的背景音乐。而肖恩能够处理所有这些不同的细微差别。故事可以发生转折的方式，你可以拥有随叙事而动的音乐。我甚至没有意识到自己有多么渴望这一点。
You know, when you're talking about stories about buildings and stories about objects, it's like weirdly more complicated. It's not like, and this is where it was sad, and this is where it was excited and happy. It's always, you know, it's like, oh, can we make it like a ponderous, but a little dark? Can we make it exhilarating but also a little sinister? They're just like, yeah, it felt like mixing paint. It felt like
你知道的，当你讲述关于建筑的故事和关于物体的故事时，它奇怪地要复杂得多。这并不像“这里是悲伤的时刻，这里是激动和快乐的时刻”。情况总是，你知道的，就像是：“哦，我们能把它弄得沉思但又带点阴暗吗？我们能让它令人振奋但又带点阴险吗？”他们就会说：“行啊。”这感觉就像在调配颜料。这感觉就像是
Sean was helping make new colors. I love collaborating with people and I think that's like one of the things I love so much about about this job, about working for the show, is that like everything that I write is like, you know, it's like, it's for the show, but it's also like very much for the person who's like producing the episode. And over the years, I like worked with all the producers and was developing, developing our like working relationships with like what kind of music like works for which people like for example, Emmett or Vivian might ask me to make something that would highlight how silly or delightful
肖恩在帮忙调制新的色彩。我喜欢和别人合作，我认为这也是我如此热爱这份工作、热爱为这个节目工作的原因之一——我写的一切，你知道的，虽然是为节目而写的，但很大程度上也是为了制作这一集的具体某个人。这些年来，我跟所有的制作人都合作过，并逐渐摸索出我们之间的工作关系，比如什么样的音乐适合什么样的人——例如，埃姆特（Emmett）或薇薇安（Vivian）可能会让我做一些能突显某事有多么傻气或可爱的音乐；
something is Katie might want music that is more neutral but has a cool beat and I felt like I could always count on Avery to really, you know, want to pull me in a new direction, you know, to, to be like, let's do something experimental, you know, like let's really blow their minds this time. And I was sad to think that and be losing that with Avery when she started working on articles of interest, which is the 99PI show about clothes. Avery was working with a different musician, to score at Ray Royal, but lucky for me, Avery decided she wanted to bring me back for this one crucial song.
凯蒂（Katie）可能会想要更中性但节奏感很酷的音乐。我觉得我总是可以指望埃弗里把我拉向一个新的方向，你知道的，比如“让我们做点实验性的东西吧，比如这次真的让我们大开眼界吧”。当埃弗里开始制作关于服装的99PI衍生节目《衣冠楚楚》时，想到会失去和她这种默契，我感到很难过。埃弗里当时和一个不同的音乐人 Ray Royal 合作配乐，但幸运的是，埃弗里决定在这首至关重要的歌曲中把我请回来。
I wanted to start off with a launching point like why talk about textiles at all, and it began with the origin of the computer and the computer punch card, which came from a loom. A loom was arguably the first computer. It was the first to have an automated form of weaving. And that's where the punch card came from that eventually led to the computer. And so this felt extremely like wheelhouse 99PI. That's a cool fact. That's a cool story to get people into the computer. And so this felt extremely like wheelhouse 99pi. That's a cool fact. That's a
我想从一个切入点开始：为什么要谈论纺织品？这一切始于计算机和计算机打孔卡的起源，而打孔卡起源于织机。织机可以说是第一台计算机。它是第一个拥有自动化织造形式的设备。打孔卡就是从那里诞生的，并最终引领了计算机的诞生。所以这感觉非常符合 99PI 的核心风格。这是一个很酷的事实。这是一个能把人们引入计算机世界的酷故事。所以这感觉非常符合 99PI 的核心风格。这是一个很酷的事实。这是一个
cool story to get people into the series. And then as I was learning about punch cards, it was like, oh, this is also the same technology that makes music boxes. It would be kind of cool to have a music box sound so that people would be like, oh, punch cards, I know what those are. If you've seen a player piano or a music box, it's that exact same technology where there's a hole or not a hole, you know, basically the equivalent of one or zero, and that decides if there's going to be a note there or not. So I turned to Sean and I was like, could you make a music box song? And immediately I was like, oh, yes, like I want to do that.
能把人们引入这个系列的酷故事。然后，当我了解打孔卡时，我想：哦，这也是制造八音盒的技术。如果能有一种八音盒的声音，人们就会觉得：哦，打孔卡，我知道那是什么。如果你见过自动演奏钢琴或八音盒，那就是完全相同的技术：有孔或没有孔，基本上相当于一或零，这决定了那里是否会有一个音符。所以我转向肖恩，问她：“你能做一个八音盒风格的歌吗？”我立刻就说：“哦，行啊，我想做那个。”
I was like, okay, how could I make a music box kick ass? And Avery didn't just want, you know, something that sounded like a music box Avery wanted the real thing. So she gave me this children's make-your-own-music box kit. So I like ordered it to the office like, I had here's music box I ordered for you. Go make a song for articles of interest. And the music box isn't really like an instrument so much as it's a machine. You eat program it by punching holes in these little punch cards. And then you run those through it as you turn a hand crank. And the holes from the punch cards trigger little times in the music box.
我想的是：好吧，我怎么能让一个八音盒听起来酷炫无比呢？埃弗里不只是想要一个听起来像八音盒的东西，埃弗里想要真正原汁原味的东西。所以她给了我这个儿童DIY八音盒套件。于是我把它网购寄到了办公室，手里拿着这个我为你订购的八音盒，去为《衣冠楚楚》做首歌吧。八音盒其实与其说是一个乐器，不如说是一台机器。你通过在这些小打孔卡上打洞来对它进行编程。然后当你转动手动摇柄时，让这些纸带通过它。打孔卡上的小孔会拨动八音盒里的那些小金属片。
Each time produces a note and you have to punch the holes in exactly the right place to get the right note and also get the right rhythm. I didn't want to start punching holes until I knew what the song was, what I wanted the song to sound like. And so I started out by making a few demos on the computer using a digital instrument in place in the music box.
每一次拨动都会产生一个音符，你必须在绝对准确的位置打孔，才能得到正确的音符，并获得正确的节奏。在确定这首歌是什么、我希望这首歌听起来像什么之前，我不想盲目地开始打孔。所以我首先用电脑制作了几个小样，用数字乐器来代替八音盒。
And I was really thinking, like, I was really thinking of this as like a way to introduce this new series with a bang, like, you know, like, how do I, how do I like make a walk on song for Avery? But then, pretty quickly, I was like, this is kind of cheesy actually, and I'm leaning in a little too hard to that. And actually, the music box part is barely in this demo. So then I came up with another idea that was like, you know, a lot more driven by the music box, you know, and sounded more like a music box. But then I thought it sounded too much like a music box. Like, it just makes me think of every music box you see in a movie is like a porcelain
我当时真的是在想，我真的把这当作一种方式，想要用轰动的方式来推出这个新系列。比如，我要怎么为埃弗里制作一首出场音乐呢？但很快我就觉得：这其实有点俗气，我有点太刻意追求这个了。而且实际上，这个小样里几乎听不到八音盒的部分。于是我想出了另一个主意，这个主意更多地由八音盒驱动，听起来更像是一个八音盒。但后来我又觉得它听起来太像八音盒了。就像是，这只会让我想到你在电影里看到的每一个八音盒：一个瓷质的
ballerina, slowly spinning, and I was just like, how can we make it sound? You know, a little more unique. How can I make the music box actually feel like it is less of a toy and more of like an instrument? How can I make it like a valid instrument in an orchestra? And so that's where the third idea came from. The interesting thing, this one kind of accomplishes on paper. All the things I wanted to do, you know, make a music box lead in orchestra. Except that it kind of lost that sort of like kicking ass like walk-on song feeling.
芭蕾舞女演员在缓缓旋转。我就在想：我们怎么能让它听起来更独特一点呢？我怎么能让八音盒感觉它不那么像一个玩具，而更像是一件乐器呢？我怎么能让它成为管弦乐队中一件合法的乐器呢？这就是第三个想法的由来。有趣的是，这个想法在纸面上实现了我想要做的一切：让八音盒在管弦乐队中领奏。除了它有点失去了那种酷炫的、作为出场曲的感觉。
But then some day later I was in the shower and I just like started hearing this kind of like circular melody in my head. You know and I was like this line in the episode, like in the script, about going around and around, like the punch guard programming for like a player piano or a music box or an old computer. And I was like, oh, I think I have it. And so I just like, ran to my keyboard to like, to just like get this idea out. The way the notes circle around, it feels like turning the computer, so the next step was to program the actual music box that Avery gave me to play the part. I took my time because I wanted to be really careful and make sure I wasn't going to punch
但几天后我在洗澡时，脑子里突然开始盘旋这种循环的旋律。你知道的，就像剧本里的这句台词：关于转啊转，就像自动演奏钢琴、八音盒或老式计算机的打孔卡程序那样。我就想：哦，我想我有灵感了。于是我跑到键盘前，把这个想法弹奏了出来。音符盘旋的方式，感觉就像转动计算机一样，所以下一步就是对我给埃弗里的那个真正的八音盒进行编程，让它演奏这个部分。我慢条斯理地做，因为我想非常小心，确保不会在错误的地方打孔，但最终我完成了在纸上戳孔的工作，并进行了测试。
any holes in the wrong places, but eventually I finished poking holes in the paper and I tested it out. And I think what was really magical was just hearing like this music that I had made in the ephemeral computer world being made by this tangible little machine. I don't know, I felt like I had really made something. And the next step was to record it. I felt like I had really made something. And the next step was to record it. And I wanted the music box to start out slow and then, you know, kind of gradually speed up.
我想，真正神奇的是听到我这个在稍纵即逝的计算机世界里创作的音乐，竟然由这个触手可及的小机器演奏出来。我不知道，我觉得自己真的创造出了什么东西。接下来的步骤就是把它录音。我觉得自己真的创造出了什么东西。接下来的步骤就是把它录音。我希望八音盒一开始慢一点，然后，你知道的，逐渐加速。
And so to do that, I recorded a few different takes at different speeds. And first one I did was really slow. You can actually like really hear the little gears turning and the little like squeak from the crank. I really like loved that sound. I love when you can like hear component parts of a sound like you don't just hear like the sound but you hear what's making the sound. I love hearing like the strings of like a violin or something
为了做到这一点，我以不同的速度录制了好几个不同的版本。我做的第一版非常慢。你实际上真的能听到小齿轮在转动，还有摇柄发出的轻微吱呀声。我真的很喜欢那个声音。我喜欢当你能听到一个声音的组成部分时——你听到的不仅仅是声音本身，还能听到是什么在制造这个声音。我喜欢听小提琴之类的弦乐，那种琴弓刮擦的声音。
like that kind of scrape of the bow. Maybe I could have done some kind of stuff to like lessen the squeak but I I love the squeak. I just wanted to let it be as squeaky as it was. And then I did another one that was a little bit faster. And I had a tempo in mind that I wanted to build to that I wanted the other instruments to come up over. And in order to get it to go that fast, I had to crank it really fast. And this tiny little crank is not very ergonomic. So I'm just like, bo lot before I could like get a good recording of like the fast take.
也许我可以做一些处理来减小吱呀声，但我爱死这个吱呀声了。我只想让它保持原本的吱呀作响。然后我又录了一个快一点的版本。我心里有一个想要达到的速度，我希望其他乐器在这个速度上层层叠加。为了让它转得那么快，我必须拼命快速转动摇柄。这个微小的摇柄不是很符合人体工学，所以我一直在……在录出快节奏的理想版本之前，累得够呛。
I'm not sure if like, you know, anybody would like listen to that, the music box on its own and think like driving. But like, when I hear that, I like hear, that's what the rhythm is doing to me. Those are like, that's the syncopation that I can hear in my head. And so that's naturally how I started playing the next instrument. I really love contrast in music. So I wanted the next instrument that you hear to be like the polar opposite of the music box. So I got my stand up base and just started like going, da da, just like driving eighth notes. And then I really wanted to like emphasize that chop.
我不知道是不是有人会单独听这个八音盒，然后觉得这很有动感。但每当我听到那个声音，我就会听到，这就是节奏对我的影响。这就是我脑海中能听到的切分音。所以这很自然地成为我弹奏下一个乐器的方式。我非常喜欢音乐中的对比度。所以我希望你听到的下一个乐器与八音盒截然相反。于是我拿出了我的立式贝斯，开始弹奏哒、哒，就像那种带劲的八分音符。然后我真的很想强调那种顿音。
So I also like did a really high note on the bass so that the cutting, that cutting rhythm would be like unmistakable or something. And so then just as I brought in this like harsh choppy bass in order to counter the pretty little music box. I wanted to counter that choppy sound with long, very pretty tones from the cello. This cello belongs to one of my old bandmates and she was nice enough to let me borrow it for this. It just has this really like full and woody sound that I love. I had all these other like ideas for other instruments to come into and like bring it to the next place and like have a huge crashing ending but something that I've like consistently learned from this job is that less is more
所以我还在贝斯上弹了一个极高的音符，好让那种切割感、那种切割节奏变得无可置疑。就在我引入这种刺耳、断续的贝斯来对抗优美的小八音盒的同时，我想用大提琴悠长而优美的音色来平衡那种断续的声音。这把大提琴属于我以前乐队的一个队友，她很好地把它借给我用。它有一种我非常喜欢的饱满且充满木质感的声音。我当时对其他要加入的乐器有很多想法，想要把音乐推向下一个阶段，并有一个巨大的、震撼的结局，但我从这份工作中一直学到的一点是，少即是多。
and a lot of times it makes like just as much sense or more sense you know to get something that's good and then quit while you're ahead and now I really love how this song ends I'm really happy with how it ended up. I felt like, with just like these few little components, I had really accomplished the things I had set out to do, which were making the music box feel bigger and batter than you normally think of it and making a song that matched and played off of the content of the story and giving Avery this opening and closing of a chapter song for her opening and closing
很多时候，找到好东西然后见好就收，在情理上要合理得多。现在我真的很喜欢这首歌的结尾，我对最终的效果非常满意。我觉得，仅凭这几个小组件，我就真正实现了我设定的目标：让八音盒感觉比你通常想象的更大、更酷；创作了一首歌，它既契合又呼应了故事的内容，并为埃弗里的节目篇章赋予了完美的开场曲和闭幕曲。
of a chapter series. And when I was getting ready to play it for Avery, I always have just like a little bit of of worry that like, okay, like I know I'm proud of this, but like the real test is like showing into the producer, getting notes, getting my ego, like checked a little bit. So like even even with how proud I was of it, I was still protecting myself a little bit. I was ready to be like, okay, it doesn't mean that you're a bad musician. It just means that this is a process. The process of making articles of interest
当我准备把这首歌放给埃弗里听时，我心里总是有一点点担心：好吧，我知道我为这感到骄傲，但真正的考验是把它拿给制作人看，听取意见，让我的小自尊心接受一点审视。所以，尽管我为它感到骄傲，我还是稍微给自己做了一点心理防御。我随时准备好接受这样的评价：这并不意味着你是个烂音乐家，这只意味着这是一个过程。《衣冠楚楚》的制作过程
was really all over the place. And I remember one day, I was feeling really scared and nervous about articles of interest. And if it would all come together in time. And I remember Sean being like, hey, I wanna show you something and she brought me into her office.
可以说是毫无头绪。我记得有一天，我为《衣冠楚楚》感到非常害怕和焦虑，担心它能否按时组合在一起。我记得肖恩说：“嘿，我想给你看个东西，”然后她把我带进了她的办公室。
And from my memory, you played the song for me and it was just like already done. It was like a maculate conception perfect. And I remember the minute you played it for me when the bass kicked in I started crying and I was like Sean It's perfect and I remember it made me feel so calm was like oh maybe This will be good like maybe this series will be good and then putting it Under that moment when like Roman handed the series off to me. It's like oh, f**k yeah, like this is this is great this rules
根据我的记忆，你把这首歌放给我听，它简直就像是已经完成了。就像是完美的圣母受孕一样完美。我记得你放给我的那一分钟，当贝斯切入时，我开始哭泣，我说：“肖恩，这太完美了。”我记得这让我感到无比平静，心想：“哦，也许这个节目会很不错，也许这个系列会很不错。”然后把它放在罗曼把这个系列交接给我的那个时刻下面，感觉就像是：哦，操，太棒了，这简直太赞了。
When you crank the gear of a music box you can make the tune go as fast or as slowly as you want as you spend the little handle around and around and around The music is read from the series of little bumps like Braille producer Avery Chrollfum. These Little Bumps stick up and they hit a series of times which create a song. And it's funny, I hear this song being used in other 99PI episodes sometimes,
当你转动八音盒的齿轮时，你可以让曲调随心所欲地变快或变慢，只要你把那个小把手一圈又一圈地转动。音乐是通过一连串小凸起（就像盲文一样）被读取的。制作人埃弗里·特雷夫曼（Avery Truffleman）。这些小凸起向上突起，撞击一系列金属片，从而创作出一首歌。很有趣的是，我有时在其他 99PI 的节目中听到这首歌被使用，
and I always get really possessive. I'm like, hey, you're dancing with my girl. Like what? I mean, it's a great song. I don't fault anyone else for using it. It's like an amazing song, but I do feel I do feel like I Will duel you sir like she is mine this song So a bit after
我总是会有强烈的占有欲。我会想：嘿，你在跟我的女孩跳舞呢。怎么回事？我的意思是，这是一首伟大的歌。我不怪别人使用它。这是一首了不起的歌，但我的确觉得……我真的想跟你决斗，先生，因为她是我的，这首歌……所以，在
after articles of interest was finished and It was becoming more clear that every would be leaving the show at some point. You know, I had the music box and I felt like Avery should have it. I felt like I wanted Avery to be able to hold on to this physical token of the best that our working relationship had brought us. And so I had a friend of mine actually make a little wooden case to put the little music box machine inside of.
《衣冠楚楚》制作完成一段时间后，随着埃弗里离开节目的可能性越来越明显，你知道的，我留着那个八音盒，觉得埃弗里应该拥有它。我觉得我希望埃弗里能保留这个实体信物，这是我们合作关系带来的最美好的纪念。所以我找了一个朋友，做了一个小木盒，把那个小型八音盒机器放进里面。
And so I had like an actual like, you know, like nice little wooden music box that I gave to Avery as a gift. And I have the box here. It's the music box that I gave to Avery as a gift. And I have the box here. It's the music box. If I keep playing it, it's going to make me cry. Like, honestly, this is my little rosebud moment. And I, oh my god, I hear this music box
于是我拥有了一个真正精致、好看的小木制八音盒，把它当作礼物送给了埃弗里。我把这个盒子带来了。这就是我送给埃弗里作为礼物的那个八音盒。我把它带来了。这就是那个八音盒。如果我继续弹奏它，我会哭出来的。老实说，这就是我的“玫瑰花蕾”时刻。天哪，我听到这个八音盒，
and it makes me think about Oakland. It's like the most beautiful song in the world. Sorry. And now here's the loom in its entirety. 1.5kg 1kg 1kg 1kg 1kg 1kg 1kg
就会想起奥克兰。这是世界上最美的歌。对不起。现在是完整的《织机》。
1kg 1kg 1kg 1kg 1kg 1kg 1kg 1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1-1.5-1.5-1.5-1-1.5- 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc
1kg 1kg 1kg 1kg 1kg 1kg 1kg 1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1-1.5-1.5-1.5-1-1.5- 1 待定 1 待定 1 待定 1 待定 1 待定
1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc The This bonus episode of 99% in visible was produced by Emmett Fitzgerald and mixed by Bryce
这集《99%无形》的特别节目由埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作，布莱斯·巴恩斯（Bryce Barnes）混音。
and Barnes. Music very clearly by Sean Rihau. Additional music by Penina Pileberg Schwartz, Special thanks this week to Ash Clayton, Sophia Bell, and our good friend, Avery Chaupplement. Avery now hosts the podcast The Cut from New York magazine. It is fantastic. If you don't already listen to it, I highly recommend you listen to it because you need more Avery Troubleman in your life.
音乐毫无疑问由肖恩·里尔创作。额外音乐由佩尼娜·皮勒伯格·施瓦茨（Penina Pileberg Schwartz）提供。本周特别感谢阿什·克莱顿（Ash Clayton）、索菲亚·贝尔（Sophia Bell），以及我们的好朋友埃弗里·施普曼（Avery Chaupplement）。埃弗里现在主持《纽约客》杂志旗下的播客《裁决》。它太棒了。如果你还没听过，我强烈推荐你听，因为你的生活中需要更多埃弗里·特雷夫曼。
Also, I mentioned this in the intro, but Rishi's podcast has recently been turned into a Netflix show, and although I continue to think that Song Exploder is the perfect concept for a podcast, I'm here to tell you that it works incredibly well on television too. There are episodes up right now with Alicia Keys and Tidalassign and Aurem. I have been enjoying them with the boys. They are great for the whole family.
另外，我在引言中提到过，里希的播客最近被改编成了 Netflix 节目，尽管我一直认为《歌曲解密》是完美的播客概念，但我得告诉你，它在电视上同样效果惊人。现在上面已经有艾莉西亚·凯斯（Alicia Keys）、泰达拉·辛（Tidalassign）和奥雷姆（Aurem）的单集了。我和家里的孩子们一直在看，它们非常适合全家人一起观看。
And we have a very special announcement of our own. We produced a seven inch record of music that Sean has written for the show over the past few years. So if you've ever wanted to hear 99 PI music on its own without me talking over it, I highly recommend this album. The Seven Hits is a beautiful object that's filled with gorgeous, instrumental music that's great to work to or to cook to or to do dishes to or just to help you relax in your apartment. We also have a digital version that you can download when you pay a little bit of money,
我们还有一个非常特别的属于我们自己的公告。我们制作了一张七寸黑胶唱片，收录了肖恩过去几年为本节目创作的音乐。所以，如果你一直想在没有我说话干扰的情况下单独欣赏 99 PI 的音乐，我强烈推荐这张专辑。这套七寸唱片是一个精美的物件，里面装满了华丽的器乐音乐，非常适合工作时听、做饭时听、洗碗时听，或者只是为了帮助你在公寓里放松身心。我们还有一个数字版本，你花一点钱就可以下载，
but I also, I really hope you get the record, the record is really special. I think it would make a great gift this holiday season. You can purchase Sean Seven Edge right now, just click on the Shop tab in our website at nionip.org. And speaking of new stuff, coming up after the break, we've got an extended preview of a brand new 99 P.I. spin-off series that is
但我真的希望你能买这张黑胶唱片，这张唱片非常特别。我认为它在这个假日季节会是一份很棒的礼物。你现在就可以购买肖恩的七寸唱片，只需点击我们网站 nionip.org 上的“商店”（Shop）标签。说到新东西，在休息之后，我们将带来一个全新的 99 PI 衍生系列的超长预告片，该系列将
dropping next month. Stay with us. And now, a preview of 99% of visible's new limited series, according to NEED. A little over five years ago, I moved across the country to take a job in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. I didn't realize I was part of a trend, but I was. Thousands of other people were also moving to the Bay Area for work. The cost of rent skyrocketed, and over the course of about five years homelessness in the county where I live, doubled. All over town you can see the effects of this, almost as if a tidal wave of wealth washed people out of their houses and into the streets,
在下个月推出。请继续收听。现在，让我们来欣赏《99%无形》全新限定系列《按需生活》（According to Need）的预告片。五年多前，我跨越大半个美国，来到美丽繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心工作。我当时并没有意识到自己是潮流的一部分，但我确实是。成千上万的人也为了工作搬到了湾区。房租飙升，在我居住的县里，在大约五年的时间里，无家可归的人数翻了一番。在城里到处都能看到这种现象的影响，几乎就像是一场财富的巨浪把人们从家里冲刷到了街头，
into tents and RVs and cars. I know these people right here, I know these people right here, I know these people right here. I know these people right here. I know them people right there. All of them are homeless. All of them are homeless. They're cars. They're renting the not apartments.
冲进了帐篷、房车和汽车里。我认识这里的人，我认识这里的人，我认识这里的人。我认识这里的人。我认识那里的那些人。他们全都无家可归。他们全都无家可归。他们的车。他们租的不是公寓。
They're not bedrooms. Beds. For 1200 a month near the college, that's outrageous. It's hard to get out of this **** when you're homeless. You don't know what your life is gonna be the next two hours. You know, it's just like swallows you up.
不是卧室。床。大学附近每月 1200 美元，这太离谱了。当你无家可归时，很难摆脱这该死的生活。你甚至不知道接下来的两个小时你的生活会变成什么样。你知道的，生活就这样把你吞噬了。
Mom. Yeah. You know what you're about. What'd you think about daddy? Leave me a house. Given just the sheer scale of homelessness all over the US, but in the Bay Area in particular, you could be forgiven for thinking there was no system in place to address it. But you'd be wrong.
妈妈。嗯。你知道你是关于什么的吗？你觉得爸爸怎么样？给我留了间房子。考虑到美国各地无家可归问题的严重程度，特别是湾区，如果你觉得没有任何现成的系统来解决这个问题，是可以原谅的。但你错了。
Thank you so much for holding. How can I assist you today? Yes, me and my 11-year-old son is home. There is actually a system to help people out of homelessness, but it doesn't help everyone. What does it take to be priority for them? I don't understand it. So they get you on the list. They're very good at getting people on lists. How this system works is confusing and opaque.
非常感谢您的耐心等待。今天有什么我可以帮您的？是的，我和我 11 岁的儿子现在无家可归。实际上确实有一个系统来帮助无家可归的人，但它并不是对每个人都有用。怎样才能成为他们优先帮助的对象？我搞不懂。所以他们把你加进名单里。他们在把人加入名单这方面非常擅长。这个系统的工作原理既混乱又晦涩。
Some might say Kafka-esque. It's all a huge mystery. I mean, we're like, you know, professionals here. You know, we have law degrees and we can't figure out what's going on and can't get ahold of people. I spent a long time trying to understand this system. Yeah, it feels a little bit like the Wizard of Oz. I guess my first question is like, are you the Wizard? Is this Oz? I do, I do have a map of Oz.
有人可能会说这是卡夫卡式的。这一切都是个巨大的谜团。我的意思是，我们就像，你知道的，这里的专业人士。你知道，我们有法律学位，但我们却搞不懂到底发生了什么，也联系不上任何人。我花了很长时间才试图理解这个系统。是的，感觉有点像《绿野仙踪》。我想我的第一个问题是：你是巫师吗？这里是奥兹国吗？我确实，我确实有一张奥兹国的地图。
There are hundreds of thousands of people experiencing homelessness in the United States, and COVID could make things even worse. So what are we doing about it? According to Need is a special documentary series from 99% invisible that looks at the system we have to get people back inside. Find it in your 99PI podcast feed on December 1st. So what are you gonna do anything? Wrap all of this up.
美国有数十万无家可归的人，而新冠疫情可能会让情况变得更糟。那么我们对此能做些什么呢？《按需生活》是《99%无形》推出的一部特别纪录片系列，探讨了我们如何帮助人们重新住进室内的系统。请于 12 月 1 日在您的 99PI 播客订阅源中收听。所以你打算做点什么吗？把这一切都总结一下。
Like what is 99% invisible? Like is it a magazine? Is it a radio? Like what are we doing? I am so excited for you to hear Katie's new series. It is incredible. Just keep up to date on this feed and you will get it automatically. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, which lives in
《99%无形》到底是什么？是一本杂志？是一个广播节目？我们到底在干什么？我非常高兴能让大家听到凯蒂的新系列。它简直不可思议。只需关注这个订阅源，你就会自动收到它。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于 Radio Row，它分布在
various corners of North America, but is centered in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative lists of supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99pi.org on Instagram and read it too. You can order our first book, the 99%% invisible city at 99pi.org slash book We have links to purchase it anywhere you get your books including signed editions and the audiobook to for all your other 99pi needs look no further the 99pi dot org Radio Topeo from PRX.
北美洲的各个角落，但以美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心为核心。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的创始成员，这是一个由极具独立精神的播客组成的集体，汇聚了世界上最具创新精神、由听众资助、100% 属于艺术家拥有的播客。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解详情。你可以在 Twitter 上 @Roman Mars，在 Instagram 上关注节目 99pi.org，也可以在 Reddit 上找到我们。你可以在 99pi.org/book 订购我们的第一本书《99%无形之城》（The 99% Invisible City）。我们在任何出售图书的地方都提供购买链接，包括签名版和有声书。如果你需要其他关于 99pi 的内容，只需访问 99pi.org。来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。